so I wanted to touch on zinc and the
eight factors which determine if you can
absorb zinc or not because on one hand
let's say for example you have enough in
your diet but what about if you cannot
absorb zinc zinc is one of the most
important trace minerals and nutrients
that you could have it's involved in so
many different chemical reactions with
your metabolism with your immune system
and your protein metabolism enzymes
neuron function and the list goes on and
on and on so if you're deficient in zinc
you'll have problems with your nails
hair loss skin problems GI problems like
diarrhea a testosterone deficiency
problem with your immune system so
number one low stomach acids okay if you
don't have enough stomach acid you will
not be able to absorb zinc now how do
you know if you don't have enough
stomach acid well if you have heartburn
if you're on anti acids if you have GERD
sometimes if you have indigestion
chances are you don't have enough acid
in the top of the valve on your stomach
doesn't close properly so the acid just
kind of goes right through as you age
you lose stomach acid and you also lose
the ability to absorb minerals so this
would be number one number two you're
consuming foods with phytate okay or
phytic acid this is a compound
especially in whole grains and
definitely in brown rice and this is
probably one of the most common reasons
why people have such a zinc deficiency
in fact two billion people on this
planet have a zinc deficiency and
there's a lot of people consuming grains
and brown rice load with phytates which
can create a zinc deficiency then we
have number three cadmium okay this is a
heavy metal the tobacco plant for
example will absorb cadmium from the
soil and when you smoke goes right into
your lungs also seafood has cadmium
mercury and heavy metals I'm gonna do a
separate video just on this though so if
you're a smoker okay you might want to
take a little more zinc number four low
protein diets zinc absorption is
enhanced with amino acids if you're not
having enough protein you're
let's say for example you start a vegan
diet and you're not doing it correctly
you don't have enough complete protein
to diet and also you're doing whole
grains brown rice getting loads of
phytate you're gonna be low in zinc and
a couple more points about low protein
if you don't have enough stomach acid
that could be the reason why you're not
breaking down the protein and absorbing
the protein and small intestine if you
have damage within the small intestine
itself you'll have a hard time absorbing
protein because the small intestine
actually releases enzymes to help break
down this protein it's originally broke
down by the stomach from hydrochloric
acid into smaller the cold peptide
chains and but then the small intestine
releases its enzymes to take it down to
the basic amino acid building blocks so
they can be absorbed and then utilized
by the body all right number five you
have a digestive issue whether it's
inflammation in the colon as
inflammatory bowel syndrome or Crohn's
which is another inflammatory gut
problem or celiac which is an autoimmune
problem with the gut if you have a
problem with the gut you're gonna have a
hard time absorbing zinc next one hi
sugar if you're a pre-diabetic or a
diabetic or you have insulin resistance
or you're just consuming a lot of
carbohydrates those carbohydrates can
deplete your zinc if your insulin
resistant you're gonna have a hard time
absorbing zinc number seven bariatric
surgery why would that prevent your
absorption of zinc well because they're
bypassing some of your small intestine
and your stomach so you've decreased the
surface area of absorption as well as
decrease the ability to make stomach
acid and you could potentially end up
with a zinc deficiency this is one
reason why people that had a gastric
bypass should be taking trace minerals
very important all right number eight
high amounts of iron or calcium both of
these minerals can block your absorption
of zinc there's quite a few people that
have too much iron from a genetic
problem and even if they don't it's very
difficult to
iron especially men because men don't
menstruate like women of course women
after menopause could have higher
amounts of iron but think about iron is
it's very dangerous at high levels and
it's very dangerous at low levels you
just need certain amounts but the bottom
line is the body has a hard time getting
rid of iron so if someone's taking an
iron from a supplement for example
especially if it's the wrong type it's
not a food based supplement they can
build up a lot of iron create a lot of
problems and also deplete the zinc same
thing goes with calcium if you have too
much calcium you're gonna have a problem
with the absorption of zinc now where do
you get zinc from oysters have the most
but realize that ores also have some
heavy metals however oysters also have
selenium which can help to offset that
toxic effect I'm gonna do a separate
video on seafood very shortly so you can
check out that video also meats liver
will have zinc nuts and seafood has it
as well alright guys there you have it
the 8 reasons why you might not be able
to absorb zinc if you're liking this
content please subscribe now and I will
actually keep you updated on future
videos